Hi, Steve  Kaufmann here ...today,
I'm going to talk about French.
I'm going to speak initially
in English and then in French.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a
podcast, please leave a comment.
So French, French has things that
makes it easy to learn and things
that makes it difficult to learn.
The biggest sort of factor that would
make French easy is that it shares
a lot of vocabulary with English and
English is very widely spoken, not
only in English speaking countries,
but by people all around the world.
Uh, I don't know, statistically, I
think something like 60% of words in
English are of French origin or at
least of Latin based language origin.
But most of that comes from French
from the time of the Norman French
invasion of Britain in 1066.
So if there are so many common words,
I mean the biggest obstacle to learning
a language is vocabulary, and when
you listened to the French portion
of this video you will see that
most of the words are identifiable
as words that we use in English.
And, uh, the French portion of this
video will be made available, uh, in
LingQ as a lesson, even though I'm not
a native speaker so that you can look
up words and phrases and learn them.
So the big advantage, therefore
that English speakers have in
learning French is vocabulary.
I can tell you as someone who has
learned languages where there is little
or no vocabulary common to languages
that I know, it's a lot more difficult.
And even though there are some so-called
false friends, the similarity in
vocabulary is an enormous advantage.
Sometimes we don't recognize
that these words are the same or
similar to English words because
they're are spelled differently.
Um, for example, wherever in
France, they use an, an accent.
You know, the aigu and or the
circonflexe very often that hides
an 's' so ... is like study.
Uh ... is school.
Uh, ... is host or ... is hostile,
so that if you put an 's' in where
you see those accents, you will find
it easier to recognize those words
as being similar to English words.
So that's the good news.
What makes things a little more difficult
is that French spelling is not obvious.
It's not obvious that EAULT is 'au'
um, you know, even the sound 'au' can
be as in ... meaning word or ... BEAU.
In fact ... is written
MOT ... plurals is MOTS.
And you don't hear the S.
... BEAU.
If it's plural, you put an X on it.
You still don't hear the X,
unless there's a liaison.
So that's just touching on the surface
of the difficulties with French
spelling, not obvious to an English
speaker, but then spelling in English,
isn't obvious to non-English speakers.
So this is something that we have to
get used to, and it is an element that
makes French somewhat more difficult.
The only solution is to do a lot of
reading and listening and getting
used to how words that are written
a certain way are pronounced.
Spelling, therefore, is a problem.
Uh, I consider the issues of
pronunciation and comprehension related.
Uh, some people find French difficult
to understand because of the nasal
sounds and because of the liaison.
So first of all, the nasal sounds the
... don't exist in English and it's very
easy to get them wrong when we speak.
And sometimes to not understand well,
when we hear them in different contexts.
Uh, another issue that affects
comprehension is the liaison where
very often the consonant of the
previous word almost seems like the
initial consonant in the next word.
And therefore we don't notice
what we're listening to.
If you...
like ... if it's ... all by itself,
it's ... when it's followed by a vowel
and the next word, it becomes ... and it's
as if the cosonant has all of a sudden
been attached to the succeeding word.
So those are things again that
we can read explanations of but
until we train our brain through a
lot of listening, it's difficult.
Another difficulty in French
is gender and is not obvious.
Whereas I say in Spanish words that end
in 'o' tend in most cases to be masculine.
Words that end in 'a' tend
in most cases to be feminine.
In French, it's less obvious.
And I'll give you some examples
in the French portion of this.
Uh, so gender is an issue.
So ... plural is an issue, uh,
but all of these things, and I
should finish by saying verbs can
be difficult with many different
conjugations and a variety of tenses.
Um, nowadays of course, with, uh,
conjugating dictionaries, such
as we use it LingQ it's easy.
Every time you see a verb to look
it up, see which form of the verb
that is in the conjugation table.
And every time you do that and you kind
of scan the conjugation table itself,
and it sort of helps you notice what's
happening, but in the end you simply have
to spend a lot of time with the language.
In the French video I will, uh, recommend
a song that you can listen to, to work on
your pronunciation, uh, because this song
includes many of the sounds that I think
are crucial to French, such as the sound
of ... that is an 'e' without an accent.
... when it's pronounced and when it's not
pronounced and it's called "Le Petit
Cheval Blanc" so it's Le Petit Cheval
Blanc but can also be Le Petit  so
the 'eu' sometimes disappears, 'eu' is
sometimes pronounced at the end of the
word sometimes not pronounced, but I
think having a sense of the use of the
'eu' this is my personal theory is very
helpful in getting the feel of French
and being able to pronounce French.
And I very much recommend you listen
to this, um, song by Georges Brassens.